clover on my name is reto meier and
welcome to this week in Android
development October 29 2012 a lot of
interesting things happened in Android
development last week and we've got a
lot more plant this week but you don't
care about any of that because today we
launched new hardware not even the
imminent threat of hurricane sandy could
prevent the release the best-kept
secrets of the year today Andy Rubin
peeled back the veil of absolute secrecy
that is successfully shrouded Android
4.2 and all the hardware it's launching
with including the new 4.7 inch 320 PPI
nexus 4 smartphone developed together
with LG well the incredible 2560 by 1600
300 ppi display Nexus 10 tablet
developed in partnership with Samsung
and of course the new mobile data
version of the nexus 7 all of these
shiny new pieces of consumer electronics
will be available from the google play
store on november 13 along with the
shiny metal and plastic we also saw our
first glimpse of android 4.2 featuring
photosphere gesture typing while display
and multi-user support android
developers live last week saw the final
episode of some of our oldest shows our
weekly Android developer office hours
from mountain view will be going on
hiatus while we retool the format as
will down in the Friday games review
look for its return when deep down
restocks on headwear rest assured that
Android design in action will continue
each week last week roman and the guys
looked at shopping the snaps out of milk
and grocery IQ will also be continuing
with our revamped app clinic we're
turning our attention to more technical
depth within and i helping to explain
not just what make what apps should be
doing better but also showing the coast
if it's necessary to make it happen our
goal is to help create a collection of
awesome apps that we're calling pure
android check out the video for more
details on what we've got planned and if
you want your app review on the App
clinic be sure to nominate it using this
Trello board and vote on the apps and
app categories you'd like us to review
in future weeks while you're there this
week we'll be looking to travel assists
apps just in time for the upcoming
holiday season as always you can find
the complete schedule for this week's
live shows a Google developers live does
development google.com / live / android
today's live wallpaper was paper
brought to you by joko interactive and I
knew you were trouble when you walked in
my name is reto Meier thanks for
watching